[Musique]
qui
le jeu de l'eau c'est un peu comme un
jeu de pouvoir ou de stratégie dans le
nord de la franche-comté le
réchauffement climatique mais les élus
au pied du mur que faire pour éviter la
panne sèche d'eau potable dans les
années à venir
sous les remous l'heure bleue du nord
franche comté
c'est dans la rivière doubs a maté au
sud de montbéliard que trente mille
mètres cubes d'eau sont prélevés chaque
jour pour être ensuite traiter et
distribuer en eau potable aux habitants
de l'agglomération du pays de
montbéliard
d'autres clients sont livrés dans les
départements du doubs de haute saône ou
du territoire de belfort en période de
sécheresse ce trésor est la seule
ressource en eau disponibles pour les
220 mille habitants
la source de maths et devient le talon
d'achille du nord franche comté
souvenez vous la rosemontoise la
savoureuse ses rivières sont
régulièrement à sec depuis 2018 des
camions citernes approvisionner
héricourt la deuxième ville de haute
saône on peut pas admettre que les
habitants soient privés d'eau ait les
ressources sont immunisés partout à
belfort à champagné à héricourt l' usine
qui fabrique l'ol est derrière moi c'est
la rivière bêtement et s'il ya plus
d'eau dans la rivière tôt ou tard y aura
plus d'eau au robinet j'exerce dans
depuis 33 ans dans un territoire de
belfort et gêné rencontrer c'est une
telle situation que en 2003 sur une
sécheresse qui met mort d'homme n'avait
jamais été rencontré des situations que
l'on pourrait revivre dans les années à
venir l'état alerte les élus locaux à
eux d'agir ce sont eux qui ont la
compétence de l'eau potable en 2018
l'ensemble de l'agglomération a failli
être privé d'eau à 15 jours près
puisque les réserves
était quasiment à sec voilà donc si on
ne veut pas se retrouver dans deux dans
cette même condition il faut absolument
se retrousser les manches et se mettre
d'accord pour trouver des solutions
aux jeux de l'hôtel car tu as comme
actions vont choisir en priorité les
élus ceux de l'agglomération du pays de
montbéliard ont décidé de forêt le sous
sol pour trouver des nouvelles
ressources
c'était en novembre dernier tout près du
doubs sur le secteur du village de
bourguignon élus et techniciens de pma
pays de montbéliard agglomération se
sont donné rendez vous pour une
opération délicate sur le forage il ya
maintenant un an l'hydrogéologue
jean-pierre mettetal avait trouvé cette
nappe à 40 mètres de profondeur cette
fois ci il s'agit d'élargir l'accès à
cette eau si précieuse qui est un peu
d'eau font très peu et ce qu'on a
signifié c'est cette partie là qui est
juste souleymane tout l'on passe par la
fissure qui est juste sous les 40 m de
marbre et c'est ça qu'on vise avec la
signification et on refera de pompage
convention a gagné d'accord
du volume mais aussi de la pureté low
profile a toutes les qualités
recherchées y'a pas de nitrates il n'y a
pas de produits phytosanitaires il n'y a
pas une bactérie c'est une eau parfaite
à dire à mettre en bouteille tel qu'il
est tel tdc à mettre en doute est
parfaitement potable et pur cdo sont
très vieilles il n'y a aucun risque de
contamination par un accident quelconque
ça c'est ça le fameux d'histoire pas
sensible aux sécheresses pas sensible
aux crues est pas sensible aux
pollutions quoi demander de plus
il faut savoir aussi réagir en cas de
crise pma à un autre projet non loin de
là l'eau de la gravière de mater une
réserve qui pourrait servir au cas où
actuellement c'est des études a
simplement pour savoir si la gravière on
peut l'utiliser gérer comme réserves
d'eau mais comme vous le précisez seule
réserve sécuritaire c'était aussi une
pollution sur le doubs on pourrait
éventuellement tirer pendant un certains
nombres de jours les mètres cubes dont
on a besoin sur le sinn de mater on a
quand même 20 hectares avec je dirais à
peu près un million de mètres cubes
d'eau et on pourra utiliser sans aucun
problème une bonne moitié sévir 500 à
600 mille mètres cubes ce qui fait quand
même une couverture d'une vingtaine de
jours par rapport à la consommation qui
est fait sur l' usine de maths et
réaliser des études de faisabilité
monter des plans de financement pour
utiliser de nouvelles ressources tout
cela va prendre des années
du temps c'est aussi ce qu'il va falloir
pour mettre en place la deuxième carte
action de notre jeu de l'eau à saint
dizier l'évêque une expérimentation avec
les agriculteurs vient tout juste de
commencer
dans le val de saint dizier l'évêque
l'eau a une histoire on venait en
pèlerinage dans ce village du sud du
territoire de belfort pour se baigner
dans ces eaux glacées et espérer soigner
sa folie
aujourd'hui la source n'est même plus
potable depuis depuis août 2019 launay
d'ici n'est pas du tout utilisé pour
pour alimenter la population de
de saint dizier à cause des pics de
pollution par les pesticides
effectivement on a pris cette décision
parce qu'on ne peut pas garantir une
qualité de pérenne sur sur l'année à
tout moment parce qu'effectivement on a
des apparitions de pi qui arrive à tout
moment donc on a pris la décision de le
fermer jusqu'à nouvel ordre oui ce
captage est considéré comme prioritaire
depuis 2010 depuis sa fermeture
la communauté de communes du sud
territoire doit se reporter sur les huit
autres captages pour livrer de l'eau
potable à 24 milles habitants on veut
aller plus loin pour être sûr de pouvoir
l'ouvrir et pas d'avoir à le fermer tous
les matins c'est une chose et puis pour
préserver l'avenir parce que si les
arrivées des phyto depuis que
l'agriculture existe si on continue une
même type d'agriculture peut être demain
on n'en sait rien mais peut-être y en
aura plus donc nous on veut anticiper ça
pour être sûr que du côté de l'eau on
est de l'autre qualité pour les
générations qui viendront derrière nous
ses chansons dans la zone du captages
prioritaires 400 hectares sur lesquels
les agriculteurs ont pu bénéficier des
aides pour diminuer l'usagé des
phytosanitaires
entre 2014 et 2019 ils ont diminué de
40% mais cela n'a pas été suffisant pour
maintenir ouvert le captage de saint
dizier mais pour aller plus loin il faut
qu'on se lance dans des mesures qui
implique des changements plus profonds
et pour sa seule façon c'est vraiment
d'associer la profession agricole à
cette construction d'une nouvelle
filaire ou de nouvelles approches en
matière de culture ou d'élevage et là il
faut qu'on change un peu de
huy de mode de fonctionnement où vous
pouvez avoir des des instances ouf ou
discuter chacun pouvait plus ou moins
resté sur ses positions
et on n'avait pas vraiment de
concertations ou négociations sur le
fond ce qui est un vaste défi à relever
c'est qu'on a carte blanche pour faire
ce que l'on veut mais obtenir le
résultat donc ça veut dire que les
politiques ont fait le choix les
services de l'état nous accompagne les
agriculteurs seront partants pour
s'engager et modifier leurs pratiques
donc ça fait toute une série de défis à
mettre en oeuvre un changement radical
qui ne se fera pas du jour au lendemain
dominique moine à est un des
agriculteurs prêts à s'engager mais sans
remettre en cause les équilibres
financiers de son exploitation
avec son associé cet agriculteur vient
d'investir un million et demi d'euros
pour ce bâtiment qui donne plus d'espacé
et de liberté à son troupeau on a prévu
damman à changer nos méthodes à tout
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour que
localité de reviennent mais il faut dans
le même temps que nos entre une
exploitation options générales des
entreprises agricoles ont des
engagements financiers humains qui sont
à tenir on a minimum le résultat à
obtenir pour pour rembourser ne
serait-ce que les prêts physiquement
pour eux mêmes pas en bourgogne franche
comté seulement trois autres territoires
ont répondu à l'appel de l'état pour
améliorer la qualité de l'eau
au jeu de l'eau il y a une carte action
difficile à abattre celle de la
gouvernance comment faire pour que les
élus privilégient l'intérêt général
c'est dans la nappe liés à la savoureuse
que le grand belfort puisent l'eau pour
alimenter en eau potable ses habitants
mais c'est devenu de plus en plus
souvent impossible faute de niveau
suffisant les belfortains achète l'eau
qui leur manquent au montbéliardais qui
eux ont la source de ma terre où on
essaye de se méfier bien sûr parce que
pma est gentil à eux de nous fournir en
eau mais nous on voudrait bien quand
même trouver d'autres ressources pour
sécuriser un petit peu cette ce champ
captant quoi le problème de cette crise
elle la quantité est aussi cette île est
la qualité parce que c'est
malheureusement c'est un problème
à matin qu'on ne peut pas être
approvisionnés en eau potable en fait
quoi
3500 piscine olympique
c'est l'équivalent du bassin de
champagney en haute saône une retenu
uniquement utilisé pour les loisirs et
que le grand belfort l'orgue pour
s'approvisionner en eau potable en 2020
7 collectivités à lancer des études pour
voir si cela était possible
coût estimé du projet 25 millions
d'euros
indignation des élus haut saônois il
reproche aux belfortains le manque de
concertation
ce projet de champagne et illustre la
difficulté de la gouvernance de l'eau ce
qu'il faut c'est une cohérence entre
l'action des différentes
intercommunalités
si chacune
ger ger sans problème dans son coin ça
peut donner lieu à des conflits ça peut
donner lieu à des incohérences d'action
entre ce que va faire un territoire et
son voisin donc il ya vraiment nécessité
de se parler les uns avec les autres et
ça comment y parvenir mais ici on a la
chance de voir cette commission locale
de l'eau qui permet à ces différents à
ces différentes structures d'avoir ce ce
lieu de discussion de pouvoir aborder
tous ces sujets et de voir ensemble
quelle pourrait être la meilleure
réponse qui soit favorable pour tout le
monde aujourd'hui il coûte moins cher de
travailler ensemble de travailler les
uns contre les autres et ça c'est un
élément important à la fois pour les
élus parce qu'il ya moins
d'investissements réalisés mais aussi
pour nos concitoyens qui rompt un prix
de l'eau moins cher
ces élus du grand belfort le savent eux
qui n'ont pas assez d'eau ils ont tout
intérêt à s'entendre avec leurs voisins
ils siègent justement à cette commission
locale de l'eau ce parlement de l'eau
qui réunit des représentants de six
communautés de communes dans trois
départements
c'est pas évident aller chaque
politiques essayent de défendre son camp
oui bien c'est pas chose facile parce
que comme on est sûr trop territoire
chacun essaye de garder un petit peu son
apéro gratte yves 2 deux territoires il
faudrait un moment dire que l'intérêt
général prime sur l'intérêt particulier
de chaque collectivité il faut une
mentalité
quelque chose qu'on disait effectivement
lors c'est la vie il faut qu'il soit
notre prière priorités et après c'est
la volonté tout simplement volé 10 et
politique
[Musique]
dans la pioche du jeu de l'eau les élus
ont encore d'autres cartes à jouer
traquer les fuites dans les réseaux nous
inciter à faire des économies pour que
l'eau potable continue de couler la
partie est loin d'être finie
[Musique]